allora ho un outfit veramente strano e
non vi posso spiegare il perché cielo
non mi posso spiegare perché sono qui in
un posto sperduto di londra ma poi ve lo
spiegherò in un secondo momento non fate
domande da tutti ragazzo mi vedete
questo video che sono fra vj e oggi
siamo il nuovo blog questa settimana
penso abbiate visto tutti fatto due
video con gli hot ob
il sior karim uno uscito sul suo canale
1 sul mio ho registrato un po di grazie
registrato un po di backstage del video
che abbiamo fatto insieme vi lascio alle
riprese del dietro mazzo sole o allora e
questo è un backstage loren sai dove sta
andando
e qual è la cosa che fa ridere chi non
possono sfuggire coop sfiga zappare la
terra
finalmente lo youtuber che lavora e
anche la mer di 86 cani purtroppo ha
finito di suonare l'allarme quindi
registriamo niente ragazzi pensavo fosse
una roba peggiore invece carime mi
insegnava che sicuro in un ambito
lavorativo differente mi regala anche i
guanti quindi possono già fare proprio
lavoro grazie cari per aver assicurato
il mio futuro da noi youtuber che i
ragazzi questa parco demonio è cascato
quanto questo era backstage con karim 5
me l'avete chiesti in tanti ne eravamo
già amici da un sacco di tempo ci
vediamo mai e perché un po pigro ragazzo
con ragazzi intendo lui non io sono
pigri tutte e due realtà però vabbè
sono contento vi sia piaciuta sia
l'intervista che il video normale questa
settimana sempre dove abbiamo girato
l'intervista ci hanno proiettato social
dream che come sapete il logo mentario
che hanno fatto su mei mei sabrina per
vedere come
registriamo dietro le quinte ci hanno
seguiti anche un po in giappone e
l'abbiamo visto per la prima volta
questa settimana non posso farvi vedere
niente
ovviamente questo non mi linciano però
vi lascio un paio di reaction che
abbiamo fatto durante la visione del
film
[Musica]
sei contento di dove siamo ax è sì bene
tutti ragazzi venite questo video sono
fa vj oggi siamo a vedere il film di
social game per la prima volta per
l'occasione mi sono ri vestito elegante
come come quando ho visto il trailer e
ho portato anche ax che sta qua che è
molto contento di questo vero e adesso
entriamo vediamo il film c'è voglia di
vedere il film cioè allora dopo tanto
tempo perché sono passati mesi di lavoro
dico di riprese e robe del genere è un
momento un po profondo quello di vedere
il nostro docu film
adesso stiamo per entrare siamo arrivati
adesso sono ancora in macchina bloggare
perché mi vergogno blogger in mezzo alla
gente però adesso esco e vado con i
ragazzi a vedere l'anteprima nel nostro
film ci sarà un po tutta la troupe ha
girato che ha contribuito quindi sarà
pieno di gente
io ho un po mi vergogno però ci proviamo
tanto c'è anche schemi difende quindi
esco ajax
da iaquinta che c'è il film anzi è un
docu film anzi un blog film niente
scappate daniele chiama gliene frega
niente ad acs alla questa è la stanza
dove tutti quanti vedranno in una vita
niente io mi siedero penso
adesso mi stanno costringendo ad alzarmi
perché mi sono seduto qua quindi sembra
degli atti secolo scorso tutti la cosa
vuoi mi sono vestito si sentì posso
stare qui a vedere il film
che problema c'è che problema c'è se
rimango qua ma guarda che brutta con la
sedia
ahia ahia va bene dai rialzi so perché
non ha chiesto sabrina vieni ebbene
questo sì che un bel video nuovo
interessante esatto
roba mai vista e il proiettore estorto
estorto pop corn e dove si prendono il
posto progetto rete siti che non riesco
a vedere il film
basta che parlano tutti i piani ma alla
fine ma c'è scritto sky origina
production non è vero l'abbiamo fatto
noi ne ho fatto noi sky l'ha fatto sky
ho aperto le foto del giappone da quando
abbiamo fatto il viaggio in tutte le mie
con raid giorni e ciò anche ragione
dormivo anche prima di venire 40 che
passava merito a dormire
[Musica]
come uno stop pirateria ci dispiace alla
pirateria su me stesso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
paziente
spero che non siamo stati obbligati ad
aprire perché comunque era molto figo
che ti si è levato le scarpe
stavo comodo ma scusami la bellezza di
uguale a un film ea guardarlo da comodi
è stata molto bella
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io non so specializzare le feste forse è
arrivato il momento di socializzare con
una persona della mia età che condivide
i miei interessi
siccome come software sono quindi
ragazzi questa è stata la mia settimana
voi non avete idea della immaginatevi la
cosa più del mondo ecco questa cosa
che sto facendo supera quella roba lì è
una cosa worldwide forse qui abbiamo già
capito sono dovuto volare a londra per
fare questo video non vi posso dire
niente
vedrete verso dicembre vedrete però che
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come senso
accertamento non mi piace anche i soci
ha capito cosa descrizione lo so che ci
siete vi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
[Musica]